welcome back to the Rich Eisen show I've
known this man damn here 20 years I've
known this man whoa yes I believe I met
him for the first time at the whole nine
yards movie premiere because I've been
felt it by this man and that is
definitely not that it's definitely
figurative okay it's not social
distancing again I felt it in back to a
fourth and final season of Brock Meyer
premieres tonight on IFC at 10:00
Eastern Time he is the executive
producer and star of Brock Meyer he is
Hank Azaria how are you Henry Don
Rickles used to refer to you Rick I will
you tell that story please Hank please
tell that story real quick at the
Orleans Hotel right that I would never
yes well you told me you told me that he
likes to know who's in the audience if
they are of any sort of notoriety or
fame in any way shape or form and you
said hey do you mind if we put your name
on that list and I might go for it go
for it right right and so I think we let
him know that you and I were there yes
that's correct
and and so he at the end of the show got
like handed a note like a piece of paper
and in a really annoyed fashion but I
don't know I think I don't know Rick I
Rick eyes in here I don't know I was so
crestfallen that Don Rickles would be
mentioning my name and got it wrong ah
it was like a total gut punch he had
done the same thing to me like a few
years earlier I think that's what he
does oh okay well now I feel better
no I feel better how are you how's the
family everybody everybody good needs
crazy pastimes everything good bet you
can hang yeah we're up in Westchester
you know where we're all getting good
and sick of each other and I am
and so it's going to be interesting
experiment isn't it's like a weird like
home version of Survivor so now I know I
know life and I voted my son off hold on
it's too soon it's too soon you gotta
hang in there you gotta hang in there
alright so let's get into it let's get
into the the the juicy aspect of this
that the New York jet fan and you
hearing the news that Thomas Edward
Brady is vacating his place of residence
to use the audible phrase use it from
the FCC is gone from the AFC East your
thoughts on that sir well it's like a
decade too late but better late than
ever I guess
and look at nightmare that you couldn't
wake up from right was Brady he's still
there unbelievable
like the stupid that this is pretty
accurate dystopia supervirus Brady still
cubing he's 58 years old
I still and it's pretty accurate but am
I not personal nightmare but yeah glad
good riddance you know I always say and
these you know in these troubled times
which if I can offer a heartfelt good
riddance yes the only fan base that is
saying that louder than you Hank Azaria
is the Buffalo Bills who he did more of
a worse number on than he did the Jets
but the difference is is that the
Buffalo Bills linebacker named mo Louis
didn't break up
drew Bludso's innards to start this
whole thing to begin with well I guess
that's why you get paid the big bucks
why you know all kinds of stuff like
that yeah and the Orleans hotel where we
saw Don Rickles I don't know
yeah I'd keep all these things in my
head for some reason you know he's an
old guy now this is very very Joe
Montana very Peyton Manning this whole
maneuver yeah I know he probably should
just stop right can he just stop I don't
know I think III don't know I I think he
just loves it too much and the the
opportunity to go and potentially you
know the funny thing is at 2021 football
season the Bucks visit New England that
will be good eats that night yeah see
how he does there and and what happens
and also be fascinating to see how
balichek of the pages - are they gonna
stay with with Jimmy Winston's with John
and one actually Chris will you look
that up it's will be a heckuva of a
jersey nameplate that's for sure no
Jared Stidham bank and then it'll be you
know Sam darn 'old you know who's your
new quarterback in there
speaking of dystopian future that's
where Brock Meyer takes place in the
final season
Brock Meyer the legend of the booth
whose career I've been following for
many many years as you know Hank
now the commissioners baseball is that
the fact of bronze correct
let me I'll talk to ya soon Bret
maverick is a moment final season is
here was not intended to coincide with
the final season of humanity but here we
are yeah you know and Jim crack my
reminding you which Iceland when
baseball does come back it will still be
imperative that all players wash their
hands directly after banging on trash
can so let's not forget that
Commissioner Brock Meyer handled the
trashcan banging scandal well I think he
would make announcement similar to this
one
be baseball games but that doesn't mean
you can't get drunk and yell about the
Astros come out right that is wild that
should be the national pastime
hey everybody let's all get drunken and
scream about the Astros and it would
cost the Mets their manager before he
even manages a game than all of that hey
folks
all of them downside to the scandal and
none of the positives I guess you're
right if you are going to scandalize the
sport at least be able to raise a
championship banner as opposed to not
even some positive involved before
there's a downfall right there there was
something that was gay is it true that
my name comes up in season four of Brock
Meyer on IFC that debuts tonight at
10:00 Eastern Time if not this episode
but a future episode is that is that a
true rumor that I'm hearing we usually
do in some ways it wasn't the case right
we usually take some kind of strange
weirdo shot at right I don't remember
exactly well I'm told it involve yes yes
yeah would you care to reveal it or
should we I mean what do you got yeah
sure it's about 12 years into this
dystopian future and black Meyer has
finally been voted into the Hall of Fame
okay yeah thank you
and he's rambling around for somebody to
give his speech because he wanted it to
be his daughter Brock Meyer now has a
daughter
mhm he finds out that he in a blackout
drunk in the Philippines fathered
daughter and she is a college age you
know and around
2030 or 2032 whenever he's gonna give
his speech his intro speech but they're
in a terrible fight and so she's not
available so he's scrambling around to
see who will give the speech and he
doesn't want to have to go to jail buck
because just out of pride and every
other reason so he's running down the
list of who's just in attendance at the
Hall of Fame and and to see if there's
anybody who still likes him enough or
has any relationship at all that will
step in and give a speech and he was
running through the list of people who
like brent musburger haven't have not
pooped in his bed and he's like no not
Levitt are not eyes and they've all
pooped in my bed so are you saying that
in this dystopian future I have at some
point made poo Musburger started this
tradition of pooping and brought Meyers
bed and then a lot of people followed it
and you're one of them it just became
this running joke I'm honored to be
thrown in that mix for sure that's Brock
Meyers so great again it returns tonight
10:00 Eastern Time on IFC tell me about
what you're doing with Dream Hank and
and baseball and dream tell me about
that will you please
Rich Eisen as you know in LA I was very
involved in in in education and had a
wonderful organization that you
supported for a long time determined to
succeed and essentially I said but I
left LA like 6 years ago mostly because
you kind of ran me out of town you and
your cronies donkeys donkeys Hank where
the donkeys don't forget I can't believe
I lost
I can't believe it in that game in that
game in that poker game yes sir your
Isengard you and your Isengard
yes sir Isengard saddle my dream school
in New York is the is it is is the New
York version of it then existed for like
dirty is much larger version they
actually have three schools in New York
and they it started as Harlem RBI hmm
and they just they mentored and tutor
kids and they started with like 80 kids
like we did what determines achieve in
LA but they had grown it into like like
2,500 kids now three schools they're
building up you know the iHeartRadio
billboard that you pass on the way to
the airport sure in the South Bronx they
bought that building and that's they're
turning that into this beautiful high
school anyway they're amazing the
organization and we're gonna be holding
events I think having our first poker
event will be in the fall I hope you
come Hank always if I'm able I'll always
be it's something that helps you out
certainly in anything to do with charity
we are dreamed org to check on more
about what this is all about and how you
can get involved in and be part of all
this so before I let you go you're
berating I asked for it you delivered it
the reason why is because my uber rating
is apparently so in the toilet that I've
never heard of anybody's that's as bad
as my four five four Hank
great well let's see what yours is right
here looks nice so I mean what are you
what are you doing in the louvers all
ranked are you making poo and a new
horizon is it's never tip always cancel
so I can that's a terrible over motto
that is pretty whenever I rarely rate
them I don't tip and I can't do a fair
amount still better than my four five
four men oh my gosh
I don't know I'm I'm I'm on the phone a
lot but I'm told that that's not that
big of a deal weird thing my god Mike
tell Tufo you've met many many times
over he gets in the front seat of the
cars and he's damn near perfect
five-year 5o rating he gets in the front
seat yeah to that Henry before I let you
go can you would you mind doing a PSA to
stay out of the pubs and bars as Moe the
bartender would you mind doing something
like that right off the dome Thank You
Siri
hey this is motive bartender from this
great thank you sir how you doing that
it is motive bartender from The Simpsons
over in Springfield they have bars
people you know come on social
distancing you know I tell you this you
only eating takeout food and staying
away from people my life is about to
dramatically stay exactly the same best
your best your whole family you take
care of yourself take care each I
genuinely miss you I you know what i
hear the genuineness i really do and
it's right back at you Hank I miss you
too and we'll chat soon I'll tell her
I'll tell all the donkey's you said hey
Hank okay continued success god bless
you baby wish you luck in the future
Twitter and Instagram at Hank Azaria
check out Brock Meyer tonight Beth Ann
Eastern Time